okay we have a voicemail number that
number is
2192 david p i really like this
voicemail as many of you know
um and we covered it earlier today
donald trump was caught on an audio
recording of a phone call with the
georgia secretary of state
asking them to find him 11 780 votes
which would give him a win in georgia
over joe biden now even if they did that
it wouldn't flip the results of the
election because joe biden won enough
other states to win anyway
but um this caller points out something
sort of tongue-in-cheek but that we are
hearing
who recorded the call it was illegal to
record the call that's the focus take a
listen
hi david so yeah everyone's talking
about this uh
phone call and i just want to say i
think it was absolutely perfect
there was absolutely it was a perfect
phone call there was nothing wrong with
it
perfect um uh there should be
doing some investigations for illegally
recording it right
yeah illegally recording a perfect phone
call is just
yeah so um
i i get that they're joking but there's
a few things here to talk about
number one both sides you know that i
i don't both sides almost anything both
sides
mostly play this game when there is a
leak
and they like the content of the leak
they focus on the content and they
ignore how it was obtained
when they don't like the content of the
leak they say whoa
hold on a second that was illegally
recorded
or it was leaked by someone who didn't
have access to it or whatever
democrats and republicans really both do
this
almost to the same degree and it's one
of the areas where there really is very
little difference between democrats and
republicans however
uh what is interesting is that
presumably
donald trump well we know donald trump
was in washington dc when this call was
made
and brad raffensberger was in georgia
when this call was made
both georgia and dc are two par are one
party consent territories meaning it is
legal to refer to record a phone call
as long as someone on the call knows
that it's being recorded
the question is if the people who were
doing the recording
and knew it was being recorded were in
georgia and
no one in dc knew it i am not a lawyer
as many of you know
my question would be does dc law
about one party consent mean that at
least one party
in dc needs to know that it's being
recorded for it to be legal
i don't know the answer to that and
these one-party versus two-party consent
things
when you have different laws in
different states when the two states on
a call
have different laws this becomes a
federal issue
and anyway it's it's kind of a whole
bigger topic
but it may not actually have been an
illegal recording here
it's quite possible because both
territories are one-party consent
uh that this was actually perfectly
legal to record
assuming some of the parties on the call
were the ones doing the recording
we don't have that information yet i am
sure
that uh one of the many lawyers in the
audience will
um clarify this for me but yes uh they
we should be outraged not that trump
is openly pressuring people to steal the
election we should be outraged that this
was recorded
give me a break guys come on we've got a
great bonus show for you today we will
hear about
our new year's vacations which were for
me anyway very boring
we will look back at 2020's covid
insurance
lawsuits very interesting we'll talk
about new food waste laws in china
and donald trump is set to award medals
of freedom
to cuckoo for coco puffs congressman
devin nunes and jim
i also almost said jim shorts jordan jim
jordan
okay why i'll tell you on the bonus show
get
instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at joinedpakman.com
and remember that we are hoping for a
better 2021
and you can use the coupon code better21
to get a big discount off of the
membership of your choice
at joinpakman.com